it came out
recently that uh abc picked up your
pilot acts of crime
um and i read that it's described as a
unique spin on the crime procedural
what exactly does that mean are you
allowed to say i am
in fact i'm the one that's sort of being
strict
about not saying anything so i'm not
going to tell you anything about
the show only in that the deal is i love
crime fiction one of my favorite genres
in in novels and uh in film and tv
um and um it's it's been one of the
things on my
uh checklist to my to-do list
in terms of wanting to jump in and doing
my
version of it and the thing about um the
thing about good crime fiction is is
that it's very procedural i mean
you know the enjoyment is the mystery
for
and the new story every week that you
can
kind of watch this puzzle and and these
characters try and solve this puzzle
um you know for me i feel like crime
procedurals have been kind of
on the net broadcast side um
have it's been sort of like the two or
three shows that have been around for 20
years i've been very successful they're
still on
and then outside of that um in the
streaming uh
uh in this sort of streaming universe
there's been these sort of limited
series one-offs
or even like you know continued like
anthology series like true detective
um but i just thought well with my sort
of
uh take on a crime uh procedural
where i'm sort of more on the you know
the basic cable side
to bringing that mentality or the
mentality of
uh of what those anthology or limited
series have done
and then putting and applying it to a
weekly
procedural series like you would on a
you would see on the broadcast so that's
sort of like the basic gist of it but
i'm not going to get into it more than
that
completely get it my thing about uh
broadcast television
is that i think sometimes the ideas are
really good but then they
water it down by doing 22 or 26 episodes
do you envision is this show if it gets
picked up is it 13 episodes would you
want it to be 22
is it one of these things where you
could do that many episodes and it
totally works
it is so the i first of all yes it's 22
episodes
if it gets picked up um and
i i feel you on the 22 episodes because
i feel that when i used to watch
procedurals back in the day i mean
even if you set it in a city it's like
how many murders how many exotic
murders that have these all these twists
and turns
can these detectives get um in a year
and it always ends up feeling a little
silly i remember
i would watch 24 i mean i you know i
love 24 but
you know the running joke with that is
how many crazy days does jack bauer
is jack vaughn going to have um so i did
i do address that again i'm not going to
get into it but i do address
all that and i sort of embrace that as a
sort of complication
challenge within what we're going to do
in the show i
also because i specifically went to
broadcast i didn't actually take the
project anywhere else
outside the broadcast networks because i
wanted to
embrace the commercial breaks aspect as
well
like i really think that there's an
opportunity here to tell the story where
the commercial breaks will work in my
favor in terms of how i'm going to tell
the story every week
is this something that you envisioned to
go for like many seasons
yes i mean you know it's we're following
detectives there's murder mysteries
so as long as we can keep that fresh
which i think you can crime fiction is
like one of those genres where
it's got it's pretty timeless people get
murdered all the time
whether unfortunately that's just the
way of the world and
um and fans like me love watching those
kind of mysteries so yeah i think it can
go on
it would have legs yeah